>> HIS PARENTS ASKED HIM TO
LEAVE FIVE TIMES, GAVE HIM A
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FIND A
PLACE, BUT HE DIDN'T TAKE THE
HINT.
SO THEY WENT TO COURT.
THE MAN CHILD CLAIMS HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO LEAVE BECAUSE
HE DOESN'T WANT TO LEAVE.
WATCH.
>> I'M NOT A BURDEN TO THEM IN
THE HOME.
THEY DON'T PROVIDE LAUNDRY OR
FOOD.
IT'S REALLY A MOOT POINT FOR
THEM TO SEEK ME TO BE OBJECTIVE.
WE ARE INTERESTED TO KNOW WHAT
SHE THOUGHT.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
HE'S 30 YEARS OLD.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO LEAVE.
SHOULD HE BE FORCED TO LEAVE?
>> WHY?
A THIRD OF 35-YEAR-OLDS LIVE
WITH THEIR PARENTS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
HE WANTS TO BE WITH HIS MOM.
HE'S NOT READY TO MOVE ON.
YOU WOULD THINK HIS PARENTS
WOULD WELCOME HIM THERE.
HIS MOM WOULD WANT TO
HIS MOM WOULD WANT HO
HIS MOM WOULD WANT HIM TO LIVE
THERE.
>> IF AT THE AGE OF 30 YOU ARE
NOT READY TO LEAVE YOUR MOM'S
BASEMENT, WHY ARE YOU ABLE TO
DRINK OR DRIVE A CAR OR SERVE IN
THE MILITARY?
>> WE DON'T KNOW HE DOES THOSE
THINGS.
HE SAID HE HAS A BEDROOM.
HE DIDN'T SAY HE LIVED IN THE
BASEMENT.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH LIVING WITH
YOUR PARENTS?
IN THE FUTURE, MAYBE HE WILL
HAVE A NICE HOUSE AND MANSION
THAT THEY WOULDN'T SPEND ON
LAWYERS, BUT THEY'LL SPEND ON
HIM.
>> I'M TRYING TO DISCERN A THEME
TO APPLY TO GET THINGS FOR FREE,
IF I REALLY LOVE A ROLEX, DO I
GET IT?
>> IT'S A PARENT AND CHILD.
SHE'S ALWAYS A MOM.
HE'S ALWAYS A SON.
THEY SHOULDN'T HIRE A LAWYER AND
GO AGAINST EACH OTHER IN COURT.
>> WHAT IF I LOVE THE WATCH, AND
I NEED TO KNOW WHAT TIME IT IS.
I LOVE THAT WATCH.
IT'S A SINCERE LOVE.
WHY WOULD THEY CALL THE COPS ON
ME IF I JUST TAKE IT?
>> SHE GAVE BIRTH TO THE CHILD.
YOU DIDN'T GIVE BIRTH TO THE
WATCH.
THE MOTHER SHOULD UNDERSTAND,
IT'S HER RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S HER CHILD NO MATTER HOW OLD
THE CHILD IS.
>> SO YOU CAN'T AGE OUT OF THIS
ARRANGEMENT.
ONCE YOU ARE BORN, YOU HAVE A
MORAL AND LEGAL RIGHT TO SPONGE
OFF YOUR PARENTS FOREVER?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S SPONGING
OFF.
HE LOVES HIS MOTHER.
MICHAEL LOVES HIS MOMMY.
HE WANTS TO BE WITH HER UNTIL
HE'S READY.
>> ARE YOU CONFUSED ABOUT THE
EXPLOSION OF MAN CHILDREN IN OUR
SOCIETY.
>> WOMEN AND MEN 18 TO 25 ARE
LIVING AT HOME WITH THEIR
PARENTS.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, RIGHT?
WE ARE MAKING IT GREAT.
>> IT'S A SAD NEW WORLD.